this was actually taken two days before
Isaac was born so this was the biggest I
ever got your fat hey don't say that
about pregnant women until me I love you
you're mean you call like that anyways
exciting news today we are gonna do a
furnished house tour finally you guys
have been requesting it from us since
forever and sorry just been so busy but
yes today finally we're gonna be showing
you guys are fully furnished home I've
put a lot of work into this place I did
nothing he did no you did you were
reporting you had some input I said yes
and no more yes i didnt notice cuz she
knew what she was doing remember how we
said that we're gonna be asian in this
house and not wear shoes well today is
actually an exception because we're
actually having a housewarming party and
we can't expect everyone to be taking
off their shoes so we're gonna actually
be having our shoes on for today first i
want to show you guys something so don't
look ok don't look don't look don't look
don't look don't look look three two one
like food like that so we really love
the feel of the light because it kind of
makes feel more each much as close as
the camera is that intimate is the
feeling that we get with these lengths
so I had to keep it cheap so I went to
Marshalls and Ross and home goods and I
came up on all of these little
knickknacks a kind of decorate I didn't
want it to look too matchy-matchy but I
also didn't want it to look like it
didn't belong so kind of a challenge but
I think I think I did a pretty good job
what do you guys think composter shows
oh this is our temporary TV because
obviously we don't have a TV in our
living room so we have the Golden Gate
Bridge here as a stand-in and we got
these couches actually from JK because
they were trying to get rid of their
couches and we're like hey we'll take
them so we got three of them and we
bought some furniture from Amazon and we
kind of pieced a little a little bit of
stuff that we already had every home
we've lived in I try to display our
travel knickknacks insulin ears so it
kind of reminds us of how cultured we
are we're not that culture and so all
these books are you see here they're
mainly Casey's to see someone I like to
read oh I'm cultured oh yeah oh yeah so
this is the living room I'm very proud
of this room if you guys haven't you
ought to be I think this is like the
best room we have and also I can't
forget to thank my really good friend
Leslie I asked her she could help me
pieces room together and she did an
amazing job so shout out to Leslie
this room isn't actually 100% done it's
about 99% done I want to hang up some
flat down here and it's empty white oh
yeah just hangs ya plan we have these uh
these picture frames yay yay this I talk
image yeah so we need to also fill these
in oh yeah this is our room or a little
show room you're safe for the party
that's happening later today yes and did
you see my eyeballs I can actually shake
my eyeballs in though rude
I don't know on to the next part of the
house follow me I'm gonna follow you MTV
Cribs style she wants my degree
fellowship so this is our dining room
area and so we're gonna have like our
old island thing that we said in our old
home and kind of just popped it here in
the corner not sure this is like what we
thought was next level for our last home
for the cooking videos I wanted to do
right no longer need this buddy you are
demoted because we got that guy this
little carousel thing it's actually
meant for office supplies but I'm like
hey why not just use it for utensils and
I like that idea and I'm really happy
with that idea so that's what it's used
for all right and so over here we have
our dining room table that mr. Papa Chan
helped fill and so this complete thanks
to him and so we have our old IKEA um
bridge so you're pointing at the light
no that one ha ha ha ha ha my key with
this house anyways moving on to this
area so right here is more of like
little knickknacks that I picked and
chose from Ross Marshalls
that's awesome except for this little
baby right here so this is our silver
play button for 100,000 subscribers
thank you guys so much we love you guys
this here is a representation of you
guys and so you are also a part of our
home and you guys are right next to baby
Isaac my little baby he's all grown up
now I remember when we showed you guys
this bathroom ahead like these like
French doors it needs to it so we took
those off and now we have curtains that
are hiding our dish a dishwasher our
washer and dryer though now we finally
up so I kind of hide it behind it these
little curtains to kind of be like okay
it's not here
there's someone naked in there uh you
pervy creepy MTV Cribs right over here
is our bedroom
yeah so this bedroom we actually wanted
like more would feel so that's how we
came to the conclusion of buying this
bed frame
I kinda like our headboard because on my
side of the bed you can tell it's like a
girl's side because it's like a fold Vaz
type of thing and then like a cute
little plant and then like this Tiki
head that we got from Hawaii and then on
kacie side like a 10 plant it's more
manly ER and then you see the dragon
that Casey's mom brought over your
racist what do you mean I'm racist your
mom project ragging for my side what
would you like that I dragon exactly are
you your the dragon anyway yeah exactly
I'm not racist but let me show you guys
this thing so I really love this little
artwork that was sent to me by a
cross-stitch girl that she actually
calls stitches with her mom in Russia
and so if you guys check out my
Instagram account I shouted her out and
this is so cute they put so much detail
in it here's Maya here so here's Casey
and then like our favorite outfits that
we usually wear so I thought this is
really sweet so I have it on my knife
then I look at it every morning when I
wake up and it just makes me feel good
cause it's like that
our family there's down here our family
all right so moving on to the vanity
area so you guys saw it in the empty
house tour hell this is empty well now I
finally have a lot of perfume use my
makeup stuff and my girl stuff my
ottoman that I said I was gonna put here
it is and then we have our bathroom I
mean it's just like any other bathroom
bathroom yeah and then so we move on to
Isaac's place so this way we have this
little the Prince the Prince Isaac you
want to talk about your room David again
because I know you guys already saw a
room tour from Isaac you wanna talk
about the changes sure the Mia where do
I begin now yeah
do you stab your drawer for your bad
guys yeah you moved it so it's not that
bad guy drawer isn't over there anymore
it's it's over here somewhere yeah right
there is where I keep very good your
dinosaurs
[Music]
all right suddenly this little prince to
this game and so the only last room
don't look it's not done yet but this
room is actually supposed to be my
studio type of thing why are you so far
come back alright so we're gonna show
you guys it hasn't changed except for
the fact that now we put more storage
stuff so since we moved into the new
office at JK we don't use this room at
our office anymore so now I need to
figure out what to do with these desks
and that chair so this is supposed to be
like my studio for like beauty videos or
I don't also try to figure out I want to
do my own segment on our channel and
I'll stick it about maybe showing you
guys what I like to wear what I like to
use on my face or whatever like anything
that I like to use I would want to share
with you guys so that's in the works
right now obviously it's in the works
but this is what this is the space where
I'm gonna be so many those kind of
videos and then in the future way in the
future you know maybe this will be a
nursery someday move the cribs gonna go
right there I'll show you guys alright
so here is the patio tada
we bought this like little fake grass
dingy because I really felt like we
needed an outdoor rug because I waited
nowhere are they selling any more
outdoor rugs or outdoor stuff so it's
really hard to like find anything now I
gotta get ready for the party and you
got a good mr. yes time for me to make
some fried rice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got bars of ice but it wasn't enough
I filled it up relatively high in the
cop back up Phil I put in two more you
want to protruding from the top the cuff
like if it leveled off
you want some cope with that um for your
house or me get in a stall your
long-overdue bidet yeah thank you you
really don't have to but thank you so
much I know it's so funny so like we all
went to Japan together right and so we
all experience Japanese the days and
we're just like life-changing so then
who we got back from Japan
Casey and I bought up a day and then
they buy iPad egg and then they
immediately installed it but we just
kept ours in the box
till this day beep so Thank You Anthony
I don't know what owns it
oh man are you serious I'm serious man
pull off your pads sit on that thing you
need a feeling you that boxers just take
off your boxers yeah good on they want
to feel that the hot ass seat oh oh